monkeys
able to transmit monkey pox to humans
causing fever aches and genital lesions
but the virus passing from person to
person has been rare especially outside
of west africa until now
there may simply be more
cases and more people who are incubating
the disease in west africa who are
traveling so there's more opportunity
for it to seed into
into european countries
another discovery is who is being
infected all known patients are male and
say they are gay or bisexual the risk
factor here has been
men having sex with men and so that's
sort of close contact and that makes
sense because the way this is spread is
through both respiratory droplets with
close very close proximity face-to-face
respiratory droplets but also direct
contact with uh the lesions that have
virus in them
the smallpox vaccine was phased out in
the 1980s but it also protected against
monkey pox
and some scientists say the winding down
of these vaccination campaigns has led
to this jump in monkey pox cases
there's no need to panic here this is
not going to spread and get into
the general population and cause an
epidemic like
coronavirus has
while scientists say it's relatively
difficult for this virus to spread
governments in at least five countries
are trying to figure out just how monkey
pox made it to their shores
leah harding al jazeera